et non elle n'a pas mangé comme la
plupart des étudiants testé ce matin
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est surtout
qu'elle n'a pas le diabète
car c'est là l'objectif du lion's club
en cette journée mondiale du diabète
tester informer les étudiants du campus
de schoelcher sur la maladie ce sont
quand même des vecteurs de l'information
et des garants du respect de là on va
dire un peu de la méthodologie du bien
vivre du bien manger
ils pourront en parler à leurs parents
et pour en parler de ce qu'ils ont
appris aujourd'hui
au final beaucoup d'hypoglycémie et peu
de diabète détecter aujourd'hui mais
l'objectif est tout de même atteint
puisque le stand a attiré de nombreux
jeunes curieux de comprendre comment
éviter le diabète et aider leurs
entourages atteint par la maladie
la martinique compte environ quarante
mille malades et chaque année les
services de santé enregistrent 1200
nouveaux cas jalel ben je suis tombé
dessus et comme le sujet était
intéressant je me suis arrêté monter
assez haut de gamme est d'aller voir la
dame savoir comment ça se passe non mais
comme c'est ce que dans ma famille on
l'a donc histoire de faire les tests
comme ça même si c'est pas ce qui va me
dire que je les mets conseillé aussi un
peu plus près de 85 % des malades sont
atteints par le diabète de type 2
souvent méconnue car silencieux il est
découvert trop tardivement
il est possible dans bien des cas de
prévenir ou du moins de retarder son
apparition en adoptant de bonnes
habitudes
je pense que la population a commencé à
comprendre un petit peu l'importance de
cette maladie ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
est très important et si le message
aujourd'hui de la dépister de ce
diagnostic et parce que le message pour
le diable c'est que plus on se soigne
tous et efficacement et moi on n'a de
souci par la suite donc vraiment le
dépistage se traiter tôt et se traiter
bien c'est vraiment ce qui est des plus
importants en 2012 le diabète était la
cause directe d'un million et demi de
décès dans le monde des conséquences
dramatiques qu'on peut facilement évités
par une alimentation saine une activité
physique régulière le maintien d'un
poids normal et l'arrêt du tabac